I will not allow the anti-growth
coalition to hold us back I'm ashamed of
them growth
growth and growth a lot of horses had
just been over my head I really had to
focus to listen to it tax cuts for the
richest one percent in our society
don't forget
don't forgive yes I mean there is energy
there but the difference in the details
yeah
there was sort of like less less energy
is now over first labor then the
conservative big moments for both these
trust and kiss Dharma how did it all
gone down we thought that we would find
out with a focus group conducted by Hugo
the poster we're here tonight in their
office is to find out what Britain
thinks
thank you
we will build a New Britain for a new
era she needs to go on some presentation
skills and public speaking skills he
needs to do that quickly I found the way
she spoke at conference very insulting
actually the way that she talked about
people being reluctant to change and
that was the reason that we were not
embracing all her ideas we are not a
country which is reluctant to change but
again it has to be done in a way that we
understand and in a measured way that we
feel confident in which is very abrasive
and I'd I'd I don't I just don't know
where she's coming from she's changed
her mind so many times in her life the
conservatives if they don't rally around
Liz truss and make it work they're
committing political suicide
foreign
future of the country particularly
worried as a mother of three children
not so much for myself but for the for
the future generation about their
Financial Security you've become used to
very low inflation
very low interest rates for a prolonged
period of time which historically very
unusual for this country and we possibly
have a generation of
um of young people
who don't remember don't recall High
interest rates higher inflation and for
them there are in Uncharted Territory
but for us you know many of us were
around previously when when Waters were
chopping and it's not as bad at the
moment as it was then I don't have any
faith in the people who are in power not
to or to make sure that we it doesn't
end up as bad if okay things are bad but
if you thought the people who were in
control were going to do something about
it you'd say all right maybe we're in
for a few rough years but there'll be an
end in sight I have no faith in anyone
yeah definitely I agree as well when I
look to the Future it's just been a real
long hard struggle these past few years
you know dealing with covid and you know
a lot of other things it's really been
hard and I can't see things getting
easier anytime soon okay things are bad
but if you thought the people who were
in control were going to do something
about it you'd say all right maybe we're
in for a few rough years but there'll be
an end in sight I have no faith in
anyone
people haven't prepared for uh Plan B
and I think a lot of people are going to
be caught out by this uh increased cost
of living but you know if if they were
always living in the Never Never Land
it's going to be all right for me Jack
for always then I think that was also
somewhat wishful thinking
laughs
foreign
because Jeremy corbyn was the
alternative yeah not because I liked
Boris Johnson then as time wore on I
just lost complete trust and he has no
moral campus and we can't have a leader
that uh just as uh it's a liar yeah it's
a conservative party should do is is go
back to
um what it stands for and to the values
that it espouses Law and Order a low
taxation high growth
supporting those who have aspirations
and rewarding those who work hard not
punishing them
foreign
have not tripped up over the shoelaces
and delved into issues of workery or
what's fashionable or some of these
modern things that seem to be
in the labor party specifically they
they're tripping up on it so I think
that's good that they're not you know
delving into those sort of things
it's like the weather it's like a
weather thing it happens it follows it
follows the wind and I think that it's
um
involves itself too much on what's
fashionable rather than what's important
they are the opposition and they have
failed to
to show the lecturers that they are a
government and waiting of competence and
let's have the answers
I just
extreme lands and then you you
for example you've got you've got your
kids now
we don't really know what you believe
sport but it seems like it's like
anything to get to get responsible folks
[Music]
foreign
I actually don't think Liz Tross is
going to survive I think she'll probably
gradually give way on various things
because she'll watch her popularity
everywhere I think we'll end up with a
labor government not because people want
the labor government but because they
are so fed up with the conservative so
disillusioned by them have so little
trust in them we will end up with the
labor government and we might end up
regretting it seven conservative bases
in the 2019 election not a single one
thought they would be voting for Liz
trust at a general election they didn't
look like there was much way back
current prime minister but most of care
style was labor party four of them did
say that they vote labor they thought at
this stage in the next election but
listen to those comments there are a lot
of doubts is kirst armor clear about
what he believes will he help be held
hostage by the left will a labor
government mean lots more strikes there
are doubts toys could yet capitalized on
it politics not yet certain